Pikachu Thunderbolt let's go
hey I'm Sarah not at the shiny I'm the
voice of Ash Ketchum on Pokemon and
you're watching E.T Canada
right Bud
you're the voice of people's childhood
for the last 17 years how does it feel
to say goodbye to Ash Ketchum after all
this time I mean he is such an iconic
character and he's inspired people all
over the world for so many years and to
have been a part of that is such an
honor
it's wonderful to have a character work
so hard for 25 years and then finally
achieve his goal so I sobbed through the
entire winning episode our newest
champion
[Applause]
how special was it for you to record
that episode because I feel like for
fans this is such a long time coming for
me it was such a long time coming
recording the very last episode was
extraordinarily emotional
battle is the peak of all the adventures
Pikachu and I have had up until this
point the reason I think he stays 10
years old is so that every generation
can have the same Ash Ketchum that their
siblings that their parents grew up with
and I see so many people come up to me
like I'm sharing this with my younger
sibling I'm sharing this with my child
and it's bringing us together because
it's the same exact character Ariana
Grande post Malone Katy Perry they all
love Pokemon has been the voice of Ash
Ketchum come with any perks and have any
celebs reached out to you actually no
[Music]
what do I hope fans will take away from
it that you should be the very best like
no one ever was keep working hard and
you may very well achieve your goals
just like I catch anything